we began looking at lebron's net worth
in july when another publication the
information reported that his production
company
which is known as the spring hill
company was looking at a potential sale
or an investment that would value that
asset at 750 million dollars so we began
looking at
how this would impact lebron's earnings
lebron james has been one of the most
successful athletes in the world he has
been one of the leading athletes to
turn his
high earnings into savvy business deals
and big investments he has really been
you know an athlete who has been at the
forefront of not just doing
endorsement deals and taking money for
putting his name on things but actually
taking equity stakes in businesses and
trying to grow them himself and trying
to you know get a piece of the upside
when these companies grow we do
estimates of celebrity earnings and
athlete earnings and lebron james has
been at or near the top of that list for
decades now basically as lebron this
year finally crossed the billion dollars
in earnings threshold it was a good time
for us to take a look at how much of
that has translated into net worth so
that ron james has made more than a
billion dollars in his career
uh but his net worth right now is not
quite a billion dollars it's uh it's
pretty close uh we estimate lebron to be
worth 850 million the distinction
between uh earnings the net worth is
something that is
commonly misunderstood um you know
earnings is how much money you're making
in a given year or you know given time
period
for the average person it's probably
your salary but that's not the same
thing as how much wealth you have
accumulated and so
for somebody like lebron you know in his
career he's made more than a billion
dollars in earnings but that's before
you factor in taxes that's before you
factor in spending um
you know lifestyle spending it's also
before you factor in management fees
legal fees you know managers taking a
cut of your mba earnings or your
business ventures or things like that
yeah what's what's interesting to me
about lebron obviously he's he has a
standout athlete on the court yes he's a
four-time league mvp
he has
the most identifiable player on the
lakers squad uh but what he's done is
he's taken that celebrity and he's
allowed it to him
and it's become the foundation for him
to invest in other businesses so um
for example he had uh for a long while
mcdonald's was a long time sponsor of
lebron james well he decided to forego
that very lucrative sponsorship that
would have paid him something on the
order of 15 million dollars to take an
investment stake in got a company called
blaze pizza lebron's business partner
had said that they put
less than a million dollars into that
investment in the you know when they
first invested so basically lebron has
turned less than a million dollars into
30 million dollars in wealth right there
just getting in early so this is an
example of someone who's willing to take
risks and use his money to try to try to
build his wealth another thing that he
owns is a stake in fenway sports group
which owns the boston red sox it owns a
liverpool football club and a number of
other things and so we think that's
worth about 70 million dollars for his
stake in fenway and the next thing that
lebron has is a bunch of real estate so
we went i went through and i tracked all
lebron's um you know homes over his
career living in ohio living in florida
when he went to play for miami uh and
now he has a bunch of places in
california we think he has about 100
million dollars worth of real estate
the l.a times did a really nice profile
of lebron james back in 2019 where he
talked about the origins of the company
name you know during his his childhood
he sort of
lived in a variety of places he lived
with relatives he lived with um he lived
with friends he sometimes lived with
neighbors and spring hill was the
housing development where he and his mom
found stability for the first time and
it's it has a strong emotional appeal
for him and so that was
what inspired the name spring hill
company is an interesting entity it
started off
as a production company that lebron set
up to to um to own his own life rights
for the production of a documentary
about his high school basketball playing
years called more than a game uh and
over the years it it blossomed to
include other projects you know that
that were produced under under the
auspices of spring hill and in
cooperation with warrior brothers who
produced the new version of space jam
that starred lebron james
uh it has uh produced the hbo
documentary what's my name muhammad ali
which is well regarded and it also um is
has developed unscripted competitions
like one for nbc called the wall so so
the production company has has become
more and more diversified and sort of
guided by lebron's philosophy of telling
stories that weren't haven't been told
telling stories that are rooted in um
the black experience they took on 100
million dollars from investors last year
and now it's rumored that they are
shopping a stake in that business at a
valuation of 750 million dollars so a
deal hasn't gone through yet but it's
been rumored that they'll sell a slice
of this business for 750 million dollars
we don't know exactly how much lebron
owns but it's believed
according to the sources we spoke to
that he owns the biggest stake of any
individual investor but he doesn't own
more than 50 percent of the business so
if he sells a stake for 750 million
dollars uh they're at a 750 million
valuation
uh you know that would be 375 dollars in
net worth if he owned half of the
business so we went a little bit more
conservative than that because the deal
hasn't gone through yet and we don't
know exactly how much he owns and so we
estimate that lebron's stick in spring
hill is worth about 300 million dollars
and after all that we get about 350
million dollars that he has in cash
accounts
um
and other investments things that aren't
as easy to track he has equity stake in
stakes in a couple other businesses that
we don't know exactly how much but we
have an idea like beachbody uh acquired
a company that lebron founded with
arnold schwarzenegger uh and so lebron
has some shares of beachbody so we think
that's worth about 350 million so when
you add all of that up
you get about 850 million dollars in net
worth we think that certainly lebron
turns 40 in december of 2024 and it's a
pretty safe bet that he'll be a
billionaire by then he might be a
billionaire right around that time
you know on his 40th birthday or close
to it or he might cross the threshold
even before that uh you know if blaise
pizza continues to grow if spring hill
continues to grow
you know if he continues to grow his
portfolio of endorsements but he he will
definitely achieve his goal of being a
billionaire and he will probably do it
in his thirties
you